so this is why i don't bother trying to
multitask
[Music]
hi i'm adam i'm t and we have
eight-month-old twins rev and skye in
this week we are switching roles
hello we met on an app there was an
instant connection the attraction was
definitely there i mean we became like
friends i will say like you know we
dated we spent like pretty much every
single day together after that so
whether it was friends or lovers we were
very much together i've always known
that i wanted to be married when i met t
and we started dating and spending a lot
of time together it became pretty
apparent to me that i would like to be
married to him i just never thought that
i would get married because i always
have just seen all growing up seeing
like marriage like a man and a woman for
me being gay i'm like okay there is no
room for me and now i'm discovering
being with adam obviously he changed my
mind
i'm sitting right here hello hello
hello hello hello kids i know i always
wanted to have kids that was one of the
first things that we talked about when
we went on i think it was like our
second date t brought it up and
we both knew that we wanted to have kids
that was a nice green light for us yeah
it was a very long journey for us to get
to rev sky we talked about all of our
different options we talked about
surrogacy we talked about adoption we
both wanted kids that were biologically
ours so one of my best friends amy
agreed to be our egg donor which was an
amazing gift one of t's really good
friends aya agreed to be our gestational
carrier or surrogate and the pregnancy
itself went very smoothly high five
yes high five high five yes girl let's
do this
rev sky are just
amazing like i know everybody say their
kids are amazing but truly these are
these kids are just phenomenal skye
right now is kind of the talker and rev
is the explorer so rev is all over the
place moving everywhere leave it leave
it leave it leave it skye likes to just
sort of plant and just
babble and scream
[Music]
and she actually gets a big kick out of
watching rev move all around it's sort
of like she's living vicariously through
her sky you gonna be good say hi to the
camera there we go yes i grew up in
papillion nebraska it's a suburb of
omaha i have two brothers mom and a dad
my parents parenting style was very
loving and affectionate and supportive
but also very strict we knew what the
boundaries were and i grew up in west
africa senegal my dad has two wives so
my mom was a second wife so basically we
lived actually in a family home where
basically grandpa grandma cousins it's
like it was a huge household we are
alike in a lot of ways but we are
different in a lot of ways we're
different in the way that we clean the
house we're different in the way that we
dress and we socialize and we are
different only even like how we raise
the kids so preparing for the twins i
read a ton of books the way that i
operate is i just want to try to be as
prepared as possible in the way that i
do that is by doing a ton of research i
read zero books zero research but i am
doing great i
mean me
i'm really social adam is not when it
comes to finances i would say t is
definitely more on the frugal side than
i am i don't know what side you are but
it's definitely not frugal
i truly think i don't believe that money
grows from destruction oh boy switching
rules this week was a lot
i'm not a morning person at all good
morning it is
7 a.m i am t today good morning
good morning skye got our bottles going
oh yeah one of the real joys in the
morning is when you greet them in the
morning they are the happiest people in
the world to see you it's the sweetest
thing so that makes the morning bearable
it is about nine o'clock and i'm about
to get up off the bed it just felt good
like i will actually get up just lay on
the bed and play on my phone for maybe
like 30 minutes i got my smoothie and i
will be sitting here getting my work
done
my shift start i don't know if you can
hear the kids crying but it is not my
business right now one of the things
that made the mornings difficult was
trying to multitask so many other things
at the same time like he does a lot of
cleaning during his shift with the girls
it's like something he actually really
enjoys doing he's told me many times if
i do a morning shift i basically want to
finish every single thing t is very good
at multitasking i will give him that
just put the girls down for their first
snap of the day which means i have about
an hour and a half now to get some
things done doing some laundry a few
other chores hopefully get a little
workout in and
do some actual work we are up early from
our nap should still be sleeping but
apparently they're ready for a party
these girls woke up early from their
naps right at the end of my workout so i
haven't even had a chance to shower i'm
pretty gross right now
it's part of being a parent when i went
to the store to buy pineapples of course
i am seeing two different pineapples but
they all cut they are adam style cut the
only thing is
one of them was 4.99 and the order was
8.99 but today
we are not gonna do this
i'm still doing adam but i'm gonna just
do the eight dollar one let's start one
of my favorite things sweeping the floor
just over here playing
another thing that i actually kind of
enjoy and really respect is actually him
making sure the kids have their meal in
the afternoon and always kind of like
trying to find like what the kids are
gonna eat i am feeding the kids some
bananas i got you i got you
it was adam and i'm like let me just
kind of do a little shopping and just
buy things so this is what i got today
when i went to the store these miniature
tongs since i was atom today i ended up
buying these small bitty ones just to
have something cool
for dinner and such just something extra
for the house oh yeah the little baby
tongs are great they're so adorable and
they're so functional i've already used
them like seven or eight times since
you've gotten them
they're great so i just put the kids to
it
it's about 7 10.
sky literally just had a blowout in peas
all over everything that i had on that's
how they telling me good night papa
there are definitely days where it's
like give me that drink like it has been
a day we got our margaritas
we are gonna
chill have some adult time we will see
them again at seven a.m in the morning
it's around 9 40 right now just woke up
i stayed up until 2 a.m googling things
online yesterday wasn't too bad
according to adam the morning shift was
actually really hard for me i am
reorganizing my closet
for the
spring summer months getting stuff moved
around and these girls are sitting here
watching me helping me out okay so this
is why i don't bother trying to
multitask they've been arguing over this
taking it back and forth from each other
under normal circumstances i might look
up how to address this
but since i'm t i'm just going to go on
instinct and let them figure it out
themselves here we are on the floor i
think we've calmed down slightly no
multitasking today so i went to get
coffee in the morning and i did a adam
style
i took a stroller t is
doing this like one-handed steer on the
stroller
and they are having a good time yes i
made a meal in the meal hot honey so i
give the girls honey adam is telling me
you can't give kids honey we literally
did it
all the time when i was growing up honey
is a natural product why can't we give
it to the kids yeah so i looked it up
and
it
says you cannot give babies honey until
they are one years old which was quite
shocking and
disappointing
bath day normally when i do a bath for
the girls
i use our
baby specific tub but when t gives the
girls a bath he prefers to use our
double sink
skye
really sky sky just would have stopped
crying i'm googling to find like a way
to help her like overcome this whole
whatever that's going on i feel like
just like the research that he does and
all those things i think it really
really helped me also
not do the research because somebody's
doing it but like also giving me
information that i actually truly need
this is information that i really really
need you know so i'm getting it for free
look at that
look who is sleeping i definitely
gained even more appreciation for the
amount of things that tea is able to do
in a very short period of time the fact
that he can do it and take care of the
girls to me is very impressive having
adam's shift kind of showed me some ways
of doing things a different way now i'm
doing actually more research and things
i've been taking more mornings and i'm
becoming more of a morning person if i
dare say that so i learned that i'm
similar to tea in a way that i thought
we were a little different in just the
amount of effort that we put in yeah
just the way that we
take care of the kids and like make sure
like they get everything that they need
you know while we do both do things our
way i think that's actually a really
good thing because what's best for us
is
probably best for the kids too because
it allows us to be our best selves that
to me is just really stuck with me and i
think brought a nice new perspective to
our parenting journey we are definitely
different but being different is how we
learn from each other and one thing that
we can always agree on is that when it
comes to the girls love always comes
first
you